- Kumail, how do we know each other?
- Well, we met at Comic Con
when we were both announced,
I was announced to be in Eternals
and you were announced to Shang-Chi.
- [Simu-Liu] Yes.
- That was the first time we met.
- [Simu-Liu] Yes. I only
asked to take a photo
with two people that night
and it was you and Emily.
- Oh really?
- I literally- Yeah, yeah, oh my God.
- Because we're approachable.
(audience laughing)
You're not gonna go up to Chris Evans
he's gonna slap you down.
- [Simu-Liu] Probably yeah.
Hemsworth too, would just crush me,
with a single bicep.
But no, it was such an incredible night.
I mean, there was a dinner, I don't know-
Would you, were you at the dinner?
There was a thing, you know, we went out,
you know first of all, on
stage, Hall H Comic Con,
which is amazing.
- It's amazing.
It was the first time I'd been able to get
into Hall H and it was on stage.
- [Simu-Liu] Incredible.
- Yeah.
- [Simu-Liu] And then
we wind up like in this,
in this room with Kevin Figi
and like literally everyone
in the, in the MCU.
- [Kumail] Yeah.
- Who's table were you sitting at?
- So we sat next to Scott Derrickson
who directed Dr. Strange.
- [Simu-Liu] Oh, nice.
- It was him and his kids,
and we talked about movies and
TV shows, had a great time.
Who did you sit with?
- I, you know, Angelina Julie,
(audience cheering)
the, so what happened was
I was, I was actually-
- What happened was,
- what had happened was-
- I sat there like a creep.
Is this one taken?
- And now look at us.
We made the movies, the movies are out.
(crowd cheering)
I think, I think they
made a pile of money.
I think they say we saved cinema.
Although maybe we just kept it warm.
- Yeah I got a big
plaque, AMC sent it to me.
That was like, thank
you specifically Kumail.
- [Simu-Liu] Right.
- My kids can eat because of you.
- [Simu-Liu] That's amazing, did they-
They got me one too, but
then they asked for it back.
Because scratched out my name.
Yeah, yeah.
- It did say, I saw the S and
the L and I was like good.
Took it from Simu-Liu
- And then I think, I
think Spider-Man maybe,
maybe took it from both
of us. I don't know.
- [Kumail] I'm in hiding.
I'm not giving the trophy up.
Tom can pry from a cold dead hands.
(audience laughing)